bonjour à tous vous allez regarder les
trois premiers épisodes du dessin animé
roger et c'est humain tiré de la
meilleure bande dessinée du monde que
j'ai écrite avait des rouges et c'est
humain le tome 2 vient de sortir je vous
le conseille des bars c'est super il est
peut-être déjà vu le troisième épisode
puisqu'il était diffusé sur la chaîne
mais en tout cas moi je vous souhaite un
bon visionnage
[Musique]
sa foulée ce truc une surprise pas mon
anniversaire c'est trop génial
[Rires]
bonjour bonjour tu te foutrais pas peu
de ma gueule tu me feras peux te le dis
bonjour j'ai fait une erreur
d'évaluation
je pensais que tu étais dangereux mois
dangereux non mais t'es pas bien
dangereux
c'est la première fois comme dès que je
fais dangereux c'est honteux de
dangerosité et de zéro et que le cérou
ses roues ses roues ses roues ça va ça
va j'ai compris un ouais j'aurais pu
dire zéro tout courtois non ton taux de
dangerosité est de 0,0001 tétouan et
donc comme ça c'est fou tu étais mon
cadeau d'anniversaire
je ne sais pas mais de quelle marque je
ne sais pas tu atteins non je ne sais
pas where marque 8 agl t'as pas besoin
de noms je vais t'appeler le robot ça
sera carrément plus simples comme tu
voudras il m'a non robot moi c'est hugo
très bien humain vous aurez compris je
vais te donner un prénom je vais
t'appeler projet bonne idée
emma arrête de m'appeler comme ça
[Musique]
partout made in fine et sur la notice
s'est dit que t'es pas capable de mentir
c'est vrai exactement
cette fonction n'a pas été implémentée
dans mon système c'est flou c'est quoi
ce robot florence c'est ton cadeau pour
mon anniversaire
ton anniversaire aurait pas oublier mon
anniversaire quand même oh ben non non
non pas du tout c'est donc ça le
mensonge
j'aimerais pouvoir faire pareil pour
former seul je le suis le rocher si
c'est pas toi qui me l'a offert ça vient
de qui
je sais ça devrait être un cadeau qu'on
t'envoie quand tu cumul des points chez
carrouf ou un truc comme ça
mercado c'est donc tout l'estiment que
vous avez pour moi saviez vous que j'ai
un système atomique que je peux faire
exploser pour vous éliminer
il est programmé pour faire des blagues
ou je ne sais pas en tout cas il peut
pas mentir c'est marqué sur la notice
cholet un bon lit tout confortable
grecque
ce n'est pas nécessaire j'ai seulement
besoin d'une prise murale une prise t
comme un téléphone portable en fait ce
que j'ai des fennecs megamix un terme
aux petits boulots tu as une prix juste
la règle pour toi ali et dont congé tu
sers à quoi exactement pied toi et que
tu sais pas quoi exactement
[ __ ] t'es obligé d'être aussi
désagréable et tu sais faire à manger
non mais je peux apprendre quoi tu veux
dire que j'aurais plus jamais à faire la
cuisine
wallace à la fin du patriarcat
on ne regarde pas comme ça c'est normal
c'est la pression de la société
voilà avec une recette trouvée sur
internet
j'ai préparé un gâteau pour ton
anniversaire champ mais ce robot à temps
mais superbe
le plus dur était de trouver les failles
de cannabis ton visage voulait pas on se
caresse tous les genoux
[Musique]
désolé pour le gâteau tout à l'heure je
fais une omelette pour me faire
pardonner
y'a pas de cannabis j'espère non cool
j'ai trop la balle et j'ai trouvé moines
et les champignons mois aux en plus
léché l'oreille à touches mais comme un
copain comme un amoureux tu as plus on
fait du camping en fait du poney qui
fait le poney 2 et call plus de cheveux
safa roger elle recule plafond crise je
vais en donner aux enfants du quartier
merci d'avoir regardé je ne peux que
vous conseiller le tome 2 de ma bande
dessinée qui vient de sortir
et moi j'ai pris beaucoup de plaisir à
travailler sur les animux je fais la
voix de rouge et notamment la suite des
épisodes est prévue pour l'année
prochaine
et moi je vous dis à très vite à beaune
toi si tu veux
[Musique]
abba